you've come a long way in Meraz you used
to be the shallow girl from Jessie you
were rude
conceited in everything we didn't want
in a friend but that's all in the past
you flushed your bad girl attitude down
the drain and adopted a brand new
personality well sort of sure you're a
lot nicer and more thoughtful than you
used to be but every now and then we're
reminded of how bratty you once were
looks like the friendships you made at
camp kikiwaka changed you for the better
the bunked cast has been portraying
younger characters for over three years
and it's time for us to find out just
how old they really are and while we're
at it we'll be revealing who these
Disney stars are currently dating
keep watching to get all the deets Skye
Jackson Zuri Ross isn't your typical
camper but she did make camp kikiwaka a
whole lot of fun
in season one Jerry was only 12 years
old but she's always acted older than
her age I recorded it in Africa
[Music]
Zuri is an opportunist and she makes
sure that her voice is heard no matter
what she has this in common with Skye
Jackson the actress who plays her we
last saw Suri
in season three she was 14 years old and
dated her boyfriend Griff Jones in real
life sky is actually 17 years old and
she's very much single Skye hasn't dated
anyone just yet but that's just cuz
she's focusing on her career and
personal life she's a total go-getter
Tessa netting Tessa netting is known for
portraying a semi evil character in
bunked on the show she's known as hazel
Swearengen a former head counselor who
lost her physician after burning down a
cabin you never know when hazel is going
to make an appearance but we do know
she's nothing like the actress who plays
her tessa is 28 years old in real life
but she portrays a 17 year old on the
show she's currently dating a musical
theater actor Joe Moses Miranda nee you
may know her as Lou hawk Hauser but in
the real world she goes by the name
Miranda Mae Lou is by far one of the
best characters on bunk
she's funny sweet nurturing and a super
good friend this blood needs little
peanut butter we was supposed to be 21
years old in season four but the actress
is a little bit older than that Miranda
is 23 years old in real life and she's
one busy lady the Disney star currently
isn't dating anyone she's working on
fitness acting and getting her travel
credits in the actress does enjoy
keeping her private life well um private
so if she is dating anyone she's keeping
it under the radar but one quick look at
her Instagram tells us that she's busy
enjoying the single life
malory James Mahoney Mallory may only be
14 years old but she's already got a
very impressive portfolio although she
hasn't been a prominent figure in the
bungs community Mallory was a main
character in season 3 Mallory also
appears throughout season four friend
where she pretends to be an 11 year old
kid who's got a passion for fashion much
like Miranda and Skye Mallory is
choosing to focus on herself and no one
else which is always nice to hear we
can't wait to see what this young star
does next
is truly the limit karan brar this actor
holds a special place in many of our
hearts he's hilarious kind and gracious
making him a perfect role model karan
played Ravi Ross throughout season one
two and three he portrayed a 17 year old
during his last season on the show his
character Ravi was known for having
dated Sasha and Connie but right now
we're going to Karan and Ravi have one
thing in common they're currently single
Karan is now 20 years old and ready to
find himself a funny girlfriend in the
past
Karan was reported to have dated Sara
Gilman and Sophie Reynolds however
Sophie and Karan are now very good
friends and not romantically linked Nina
Lou Nina has grown up a lot since we
last saw her on the Disney Channel but
she's still known for portraying Tiffany
Chen on bunked and a lot of fans wished
she was still part of the kikiwaka gang
tiffany was a devoted student who always
did her best to please her mother and
grandmother well I don't mind turning in
myself hi mom but nothing was ever good
enough
Nina played a twelve-year-old in season
two a bunt but in real life the actress
is 15 years old although her on-screen
character Tiffany had a little crush on
Ravi Ross it appears that Nina isn't
dating in the slightest much like the
rest of the cast Nina isn't pressed to
get into a relationship Kevin Quinn
actor Kevin Quinn is the man behind
Xander McCormack it's hard to imagine
what bunk'd would have been like without
Emma's love interest Xander these two
are just perfect for each other
unfortunately Xander and Emma aren't
dating in real life in bungs Kevin
portrayed a twenty-year-old camp
counselor but in reality kevin is 22
years old and believe it or not but
Kevin isn't dating anyone he's single
and available
Peyton lists Peyton lists might no
longer be acting on the Disney Channel
but she's still one of the most
celebrated stars from bunked and Jessie
Peyton appeared on bunks from 2015 to
2018 but she ultimately decided to leave
the Disney Channel behind to pursue new
endeavors last we saw Emma she was 19
years old and dating
sandir Emma you don't say yes I will I'd
love to go out with you Xander but in
real life Peyton is 21 years old and
single Peyton has had two serious
relationships in the past she dated the
late Cameron Boyce from 2012 to 2015 and
actor Cameron Monaghan from 2017 to 2019
and that's a wrap
which bunks star is your favorite tell
us in the comments section thanks for
watching
hit that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up we'll see you next
time
on the things
[Music]